these radicalized democrat party has
moved further away from the voters they
need to win in 2020 they still have no
clue unbelievable really how to speak to
the working-class white voters let alone
how to get their votes so we told you
last night about how the Democrats are
leaving the white working-class behind
now it partly explains why the president
won of course in 2016 and even the New
York Times had to admit it but now with
the left trying to woo the white
working-class all again how is Trump
going to protect this significant voting
bloc joining me now exclusively is Brad
parts Cal campaign manager for Trump
2020 I can't believe Brad were at 20/20
now what is the campaign gonna do to
lock down that base voter some Trump
voters turned against Republicans in
2018 that's a fact how are you gonna
bring him back well I do think there's a
little misinformation about that there
was a lot of people that said that from
14 to 18 that suburban white women left
they didn't there's different types of
people come out for different types of
cycles so I think it's hard to look at a
midterm without the president of the
ticket and say oh they turned against
him now look I think the president has
done things I mean if you look at the
budget you know with family leave I
think if you look at what we've done and
the way the president's pushing it's
socialized medicine and you suburban
moms really want like what pushing
against what they want bureaucratic
pushing against that meaning that you
know do these moms really want their
kids sitting in lines waiting to say hey
we get you know but they freak out the
women freak out because of the tweets
the tone I can't tell you how many women
that I talk to like I like the money in
my pocket I wish you wouldn't tweet so
much and I always say look it's that's
part of who he is he connects with the
voters that way that's how he does it
but for women it's like they love the
charming Trump they love Trump with the
arm around someone a little
self-deprecating which we see and I've
said this on the show many times so he's
if he's watching he knows what I'm
saying but women like that kind of charm
Obama had it Clinton has it and Trump
does have it does have it how does he
deploy it we'll show it and maybe that's
something we need to show more I one
thing I always say when I get
interviewed is how great he is in person
and how how funny is I and you probably
know this too
I mean I've sent an airforce one while
he's throwing starbursts at me you know
I mean he's actually a fun guy and he
really likes people but he sees it as a
sign of weakness to come out on stage
and try to be too jokey he says this is
serious business I'm the president and
I'm gonna kick blank and take names
which people also like but that is
something that I think for this election
they're not going to be there they're
not gonna be caught off guard the left
is like we're not gonna be caught off
guard we were in 2016 no more yeah look
I think we have a lot of candidates we
don't know it's gonna be on the other
side yet and what and what the position
the president take look I think this
president is one of the best marketers
in American history I think he
understands the people he understands
how to communicate to people and look
he's going to he's gonna move in a way
based off with other candidates like and
I think I think either way though I
think he's gonna stay strong he's
fighting for his country he did this for
no other reason but to save the country
and I don't think he's going to move
away from that and I hope he does it
because it's still how we won the
election and that's gonna be how he
continues to win now it's been floated
that Trump could be sabotaging his own
2020 one of my colleagues on Fox Tucker
Carlson was like maybe he doesn't really
want to run in 2020 and Tuckers not the
only person who said that others have
said that is there anything to this well
we were building one of the largest
political campaign operations in history
I think he's put so much emphasis in
what we're building 2020 I go in weekly
and given these reports he'd be wasting
a considerable amount of time which he
does not like to do last month Politico
reported that if some advisers are
telling the president to hold off on
twenty20 rallies now whose bright idea
is that is that accurate because it
seems like he gets energized by the
right now I don't think that's accurate
what we talked about doing is is mixing
official events with campaign rallies he
needs to get out on the road also and
talk about that all of his achievements
all the promises have been kept and get
out there and do those things but
rallies aren't going away we already
have a couple in line for this month
we're gonna continue to be out there the
president gonna get out there engage
with people by the way they're huge data
mining operations worth they're
important for multiple reasons yeah so
you're getting emails that these rallies
no cell phone numbers Oh cell phone
right the last rally we got over 100,000
cell phone numbers now people say brad
is so young he's like this tech guy
they said in 2016 who is this guy grande
cook and then he ends up winning and now
we understand other campaigns are trying
to find their own bread yeah reading it
it's poor school ization as they called
it was the term which I became a verb
are scaling up yeah
look I think it's I think it shows they
all talk about how the President did
know how to run a campaign now they're
all trying to copy his campaign it goes
to show I wish they would copy his
policies because he knows the right
policies to get the country fixed as
well it's ironic that they've chosen
this but what's fact is the world's
change markings being driven more and
more to cell phones technologies and the
Internet and they're chasing it or
you're going to pinpoint the person on
the block who cares about the issue
you're gonna get that in the house so
families that disagree yeah families
disagree we target them differently look
most of us have an individual track it's
not by an address we create our own map
and our own steps across the internet
and that's how we and we tracked that
and one candidate you're focused on yeah
I look I just said today I said I had to
go the office backs by a bigger binder
because I'm trying to track all these
candidates
it's gonna get so thick I mean I'm
flipping through the pages I think right
now I don't see any clear person that's
is stepping up to the president is soda
could you flip it now I think that New
Mexico Minnesota New Hampshire Nevada I
think are all good places for us to be
right now you're gonna flip one that's
your goai yeah two or three or four
that's my goal alright be a good night
fight if I get more than two I know
you're at Air Force Andrews Air Force
Base early tomorrow morning thanks for
joining us thank you very much thank you
very much all right